estamos aquí aplicando fórmulas de suma
de ángulos entonces bueno aquí se nos
dice que teta está entre 0 y pi y se nos
pide escribir una fórmula para seno de
teta en términos de coste no de dos
tetas entonces bueno te invito a que a
que lo intentes a que pongas pausa el
vídeo y bueno suponiendo que ya lo
hiciste vamos a continuar con este
ejercicio yo aquí tengo una copia del
ejercicio ya lista entonces bueno vamos
a trabajar sobre esto ok
coseno de dos tetas yo sé algo sobre la
fórmula de para la suma de ángulos de
hecho yo sé que el coste no de la suma
de dos ángulos es igual a esta fórmula
el coste no de alfa más beta el coste no
de alfa más beta esto está formulada
bueno esto es igual al coseno del primer
ángulo coseno de alfa por el coseno de
beta coseno de beta
- el seno del primer ángulo
- seno de alfa
por el seno del segundo ángulo por el
seno de beta entonces el coseno de alfa
más beta es igual al coseno de alfa por
coseno de beta - seno de alfa por el
seno de beta
ahora se nos pide que escribamos el seno
de teta en términos de coste no de dos
zetas y quienes coseno de dos t está
bueno
veamos la fórmula que escribir en coseno
de alfa más beta para que nos sirve
porque nos puede ayudar esto o keiko
seno de dos tetas es simplemente el
coseno de dos veces teta o sea que está
más zeta
ajá entonces bueno el coste no de teta
más que está usando la fórmula que
conocemos para sumar dos ángulos esto
esto es igual al coste no del primer
ángulo por el coseno del segundo ángulo
menos el seno del primer ángulo por el
seno del segundo ángulo entonces coste
no de teta por josé no de teta - seno de
teta menos lo escribo con los mismos
colores por eso tardó bastante pero ok
ahorita sale esto entonces seno de teta
hay me equivoqué ahí
si se nota que ese no verdad entonces
seno de teta por el seno de teta ham por
seno de teta ahí está ok perfecto vamos
a seguir simplificando esto entonces ok
esto es igual coseno de teta por ccoo
seno de teta es simplemente coseno
cuadrado de teta después restamos
tenemos menos seno de teta por seno de
teta es esto es igual a seno cuadrado de
teta seno cuadrado de teta entonces ya
escribimos a coseno de dos teta en
términos de coseno cuadrado de teta y
seno cuadrado de teta pero queremos
escribirlo en términos de seno de teta
entonces si podemos expresar a coseno
cuadrado de teta en términos de seno
sabemos por la identidad pitagórica que
coseno cuadrado de teta más seno
cuadrado de teta esto es igual a 1
ajá esto es igual a 1 o podemos decir
que coseno cuadrado de teta simplemente
el resto de ambos lados de la ecuación
seno cuadrado del teeti me queda uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta entonces
coseno cuadrado de teta es igual a uno
menos seno cuadrado de teta lo voy a
sustituir aquí tengo que que coseno de
dos teta es igual a uno
escribo uno menos seno cuadrado de teta
1 - seno cuadrado de teta
- lo que tengo en amarillo seno cuadrado
de teta entonces menos seno cuadrado de
teta ahora observa que aquí tenemos este
término dos veces entonces tenemos que
coseno de dos teta
esto es igual a 1
pongo 1 menos dos veces seno cuadrado de
teta dos veces seno cuadrado de teta
entonces ya con esto voy a multiplicar
ambos lados por un menos uno para
cambiar el orden tengo que menos coste
no de dos teta es igual a dos senos
cuadrado de teta
- 1
- 1 y ahora lo que voy a hacer es sumar
a ambos lados de la ecuación un 1
entonces lo que obtengo acá lo voy a
hacer lo que obtengo
es 1 - coseno de dos tetas coste no de
dos tetas eso es igual a dos seno
cuadrado de teta dos seno cuadrado de
teta ahora voy a dividir ambos lados de
la ecuación entre 2
entonces debido a este lado entre dos y
debido a este lado entre dos de esa
manera me deshago yo de este 2 con este
eso se cancela y tengo que seno cuadrado
de teta es igual a 1 menos coste no de 2
detrás sobre 2 o lo que es lo mismo seno
de teta es igual a más menos la raíz
cuadrada de uno de uno menos coseno de
dos tetas coseno de dos tetas
esto sobre 2
y ahora la pregunta es cuál voy a
considerar la positiva o la negativa
veamos aquí tenemos información que está
está entre 0 y p entonces lo que haré es
dibujar un círculo unitario o bueno
entonces dibujo el círculo unitario ok
aquí está 0 radiales y acá está pin
radiales
ajá entonces te da está entre entre el
primero y el segundo cuadrante porque
aquí está theta entre 0 y pi entonces
bueno por ejemplo el ángulo theta podría
ser este ángulo oeste pero no puede ser
éste éste no puede ser entonces lo borro
ahora sabemos que el seno el seno de un
ángulo esta es la es la coordenada y
entonces
ok aquí ese aquí estaría por ejemplo el
el ángulo y sabemos que está en el
primero el segundo cuadrante no puede
estar en el tercero y en el cuarto
cuadrante así que la raíz será positiva
entonces lo escribo acá abajo en déjame
voy un poco hacia abajo ahí
ok entonces seno de teta
seno de teta será igual a la raíz
principal será igual a la raíz positiva
de 11 menos coseno de dos tetas
todo esto bueno
sobre 2 sobre 2 ahora vamos a ver si
obtuvimos bien la respuesta entonces
aquí voy a escribir raíz cuadrada abro
paréntesis y adentro voy a poner 1 -
menos coseno de 2 de tal
y esto esto sobre 2
veamos si tenemos que la respuesta
carita feliz perfecto entonces estamos
en lo correcto nos vemos